Roisin from iran married a german man in
2006 she moved to Berlin to be with him
after her husband left her she stayed in
the German capital today Roisin is an
executive assistant at a large
pharmaceutical company Constantine had
left Moscow because of the growing
anti-semitism he felt there and
emigrated to Germany with his family he
had problems adjusting then his wife
left him taking this small son with her
now he and his new family live in
Lightsey and he works as a singing
teacher
Florina came to germany as a tour guide
during the 2006 Soccer World Cup and
hoped to stay here in Mexico she
experienced discrimination because of
her indigenous roots but because she had
no visa she had to return to her country
Florina then worked with indigenous
people in the south of Mexico and
received the surprise offer of a
scholarship to an elite private
university in Mexico City Amira fled
Togo at the age of 16 and applied for
asylum in Munich he lived in an
orphanage with other refugees he
finished secondary school and began an
apprenticeship in a bakery but his
application for asylum was rejected then
came a change to the law because Emir
had successfully completed his
vocational training he received a
temporary residence permit his guardian
Albert was very supportive throughout
that time
today Ahmir lives in a rented apartment
in munich
in Winton live in assistance while it's
not easy to live in Munich rent is so
incredibly expensive if you want to live
just a little bit better you have to
work hard bites
Aamir is now a certified Baker he
usually works the night shift and he has
an extra job with a cleaning crew how
about the Monica Bay I'm still working
in my old bakery where I did my
apprenticeship it still means a lot to
me because I had to struggle for many
long years the atmosphere at work is
turned positive for me especially since
I got my certification that's compared
to before when I was an apprentice back
then I had a lot of problems because of
stress with my co-workers and things
like that once I had to talk with my
boss I was having a problem with racism
and he said to me America
it's difficult I've always worked with
black people in my business but not in
the Bakehouse you have to fight your own
battles it's hard for you because the
people they're not used to Africans or
people of color so I just closed my eyes
and ears and that helped a lot it's a
weekly see if he'll give it up - or not
I think at some point I'll take the exam
to become a master baker that's one of
my goals and I'll have to work hard
because it's not easy there are mostly
weeklies after albeit not but this is
nice alpha
Becca listen it's time to pray
in Mexico City
Florina is also finding life quite
difficult
happy L miss today's every day is
stressful here too many people's too
much traffic too much noise it was
different in Germany It was as if a
weight had been taken off my shoulders
the lifestyle was very relaxed there and
when you come here that's immediately
stressful stress
lava can be done in my university
scholarship only covers the tuition
there's no money for food or rent or
transportation Vienna para parar me
transport a jetting autogas catalogs I
have to work in order to feed myself I
have to hold down two jobs at the same
time I won at the University and another
one there's not enough money just enough
to get them giggling Mido
dango I'll go a specific about I have a
certain amount I can spend every day and
nothing more
yes there's very little it's just enough
to live on I make do with the minimal
Guney so Josiah Stowell baby me and
Oconee so is Kaname Nemo good morning
one kilo of carrots please Florina
shares an apartment with her sister
Veeru Sunday is the only day they have
time to spend a few hours together
eco-mat FYI yeah so how much boxing
yesterday boxing I'm already in the room
really you're in the ring yeah we're
trying out the punches yeah it's
incredible
you're even more extreme than me you
know I never thought you'd start boxing
you should try it you're the right
weight the right weight but no strength
I feel much too weak to hit someone with
my arms I think I can work better using
my mind okay so the traumas gonna
maintain color physical
in Berlin Roisin is meeting up with her
Iranian friend corner
do you dance salsa sometimes if I find a
good partner yes in salsa the man has to
be a good dancer like last night I don't
think German men are good at salsa no
they can't like in dance class
ein zwei drei eins wife you now turn and
some of them even forget to turn once I
was dancing with this guy who seemed to
be reading out loud typical German right
Berlin's annual carnival of cultures is
in full swing hey where we come from you
can't go around like that we don't
normally dress like this either well
once a year it's nice right machine look
at me ciao
suffer all of you suffer alone just
alone
Loic what a long icon I shall Allah
Allah Muhammad Rasul II know I long ago
send me a lord you gonna feed her Allah
Allah
as from the saloon with mustafa kamala
as a Muslim I have to pray five times a
day they work my colleagues will say I'm
here don't you have to say your prayers
they know I pray during my break I was
born a Muslim and when I see something
in the news or on television about Islam
and violence and that people think we're
evil people actually Islam is about
peace and people living together without
problems
amir has few german friends most of his
acquaintances are from africa
help kind of lublin here though I don't
have any problems here but when I'm
sitting on my bed or my sofa wherever I
think of my homeland it's a sad fact
that you always carry homesickness in
your heart I think God I have my brother
and friends but not my parents
Cafe Kiev in Lightsey is a popular
meeting place for immigrants from the
former Soviet Union Constantine and his
band are giving a concert this evening
he describes it as a protest against the
suppression of civil rights and freedom
of expression in Russia there have been
huge changes in Russia over the past 20
years everything is still in a state of
flux it's boiling over because they're
sensitive people the artists react
especially sensitive to here prove Linea
since the elections widely considered
fraudulent Konstantin has been anxiously
watching events in his old country he's
outraged at the way the government
treats its opponents in his song about
Putin the pain of the Russian people is
contrasted with the cynicism of the
regime
plastidip - los profetas
are done it's my study Putin Christmas
right outside cafe Kiev a group of young
Germans are demonstrating for more
self-determination for the arts in
lighting
Tiago with tourists I think every
society has its problems in Russia if
there are also lots of people who simply
want to be heard
officially there are no political
prisoners there but I know many people
who've been convicted because they don't
agree with the ruling system one year
with a nice across the street system and
my ass over the store the freedom of
expression I experienced here means that
I can express myself without restriction
if someone disagrees with me I can
debate with him and I know that I won't
end up in jail or have to pay a million
euro penalty I step on the middle dear
brother
changes the demand of our hearts changes
the demand of our eyes Constantine is
singing a song from the perestroika
era it seems as relevant today as it did
back then
let's see I think my last trip to around
was the worst I've ever taken yeah I had
the impression that people are not doing
well at all
there are a lot of problems in my
families and all the friends I saw was
somehow dissatisfied with their lives
because of the inflation and everything
people are at the end of their tether
everything is very expensive they have
no freedom and everything is dying so I
didn't feel very comfortable and I've
decided not to go next year I'm planning
to cut down I'll go back every two years
not every year I need some distance from
my homeland estancia hi my regime has
invited some co-workers over for the
evening she's going to Florida on
vacation soon to visit an Iranian friend
let's start have you checked out the
weather there pretty warm when do you
leave Roisin on Thursday this Thursday
yes first Orlando then Miami Miami we
say mia me do you have an itinerary
no Iranians never read guidebooks
Iranians are more spontaneous than we
Germans pioneer for eight months and
doesn't know his way around yet he said
I can be the tour guide is it curry
cumin come up or what he just wanted to
leave around that's why he applied to a
university there everybody wants to
leave her on
in Mexico City Florina is meeting up
with Karen her friend and German teacher
sometimes I think I'm not going to make
it you have to eat properly why don't
you come over for lunch I always cook
something I do eat but often I don't
have time or I'm not hungry because I'm
stressed out
but I want to keep learning and studying
you're sure about that yes definitely
and Germany you're still interested in
Germany couldn't you get your masters
here I think Germany is better
I've been studying history and all those
philosophers and historians there from
Germany a lady say philosophy
a story cow let us feed a Deutsch now
Germany also has lots of social welfare
projects and things like that I read
lots of books books by Germans you
should go to this website called study
in Germany and all the political parties
have foundations at the moment I'm in
touch with people who work with the rosa
luxemburg foundation because they
support projects related to women's
equality and they also have grants for
projects abroad projects abroad as well
yes but also to study in Germany I'd be
interested in that I think you could go
there early enough there would
definitely be a chance right good and
then we'll have to do a little more
German don't you think
if Adina I have the will and energy to
support myself mind of a lot of young
guys just sit back and collect welfare
benefits but I'll keep fighting until I
reach my goals by my own stop
more month on vacation I think if
everything works out I'll get married
and have a family I'd like to be with
the Muslim woman that's my wish
continue 14 miles on State Route 60 west
Roisin is traveling in Florida with her
old friend I am
from Tehran
they talk about their experiences as
Emma grades and the loss of their
homeland
some I love inside the first three
months were so hard I'd sit at the
window in the evening longing to hear
voices and noises from back home like in
the streets and alleyways of my hometown
here these young Americans laughing and
talking in a different language
it was so infuriating it's hard to
believe someone can be so bothered by
that but I really wanted to hear
something Persian something in my mother
tongue I don't know if you experienced
that when you out of course I did
three months is such a short amount of
time for me the first year was very
difficult of course I had Thomas who
supported me but it was still very hard
it really took two years for that to get
better I can honestly say the first two
years were tough especially the first
year and then it got better but I had to
start working before I started to feel
that Berlin was my city and my home man
I'd love to get out some sided card I
saw scared I'm can barely and shot at me
awfully so you knew you were gonna stay
there yes because a person like me who's
been working for years identifies
herself through her work am i all
finished with that quesadilla okay
have you gotten accustomed to German
culture how do you see the difference to
America for instance I think I've become
a bit like the Germans I don't believe
it's simply chance did you end up in a
particular country it's something inside
you leads you there my way of thinking
is kind of German so that's perhaps why
I ended up there Konstantin has invited
his friends to a barbecue in his parents
in-laws allotment garden both of my
chosen my own fate in my path and wine
yes I live in Germany I have no reason
to complain so everything is going very
nicely more than anything I want my
loved ones to be healthy and happy
well such an opportunity
as far as relations between Jews and
Germans I know that everything related
to World War two is a painful topic for
Germans the people here acknowledged the
situation smoothly have accepted their
historical responsibility for the
terrible crimes and show remorse pacaya
to them with the majority of historians
talk about it would the people I meet at
Creek theatres Pavel some of them know
I'm Jewish
it doesn't seem to be an issue for them
like most expatriates Constantine and
his friends compared life in their new
country with that in the old one they've
had varied experiences integrating into
German society much experience with
bureaucracy here but it's like night and
day I agree 100% like they say in Russia
you can find a solution to every problem
but it's illegal you pay the money and
the problem is solved here it depends on
the individual person or official and
they're all different
exactly on the day we arrived in Leipzig
they said to us if you don't like it
here you can go back home just because
we asked if we could have a separate
room there we are in a room with 14
strangers and they say to us go back to
where you came from
we could hear cups with uh since we came
to Germany ten eleven years ago there
hasn't been a single day when my husband
and I felt ill treated we're grateful to
Germany for this chance in Ukraine we
had no opportunities here we have our
cafe I'm finishing up job training and
our children are growing up safe and
secure
in momentous and that's the moment my
job is very stressful because we're
restructuring the department I have a
new boss and I'm not sure what's going
to happen
the uncertainty isn't so nice
there's also some uncertainty in my
private life
I keep wondering how things will
continue will I always be alone or will
I meet someone to love even where the
this is Sean it's so typical of Berlin
in the summertime when I walk along the
river and see couples kissing or lying
together in the Sun I can't help but ask
myself why don't I have a real partner
in the evening Roisin tells a friend
about her experiences with online dating
and always sitting in front of the
computer looking through profiles and
then writing it's exhausting and those
main dating sites like partnership
maneuver or elite cost fifty euros a
month fifty euros this one here is much
cheaper and you can see everything about
them this is a manager he studied
economics he comes from the state of
his'n oh I thought he was Iranian
no he's German but you did have this
Iranian no no I don't want one there was
an Iranian who was interested but this
one is a German from hessin he's not
from Berlin no but he lives in Berlin
yes he's been here for seven years just
like me
he lives in friedrich science and the
way he talks so calmly and we had a
really good conversation I mean either
he's good or he's not and if not so much
for him I see
at a university in Mexico Florina is
participating in a book project students
with indigenous roots are telling
stories about their often difficult
childhoods
I looked for ways I could work in the
field I asked my family my grandparents
if they knew of anyone looking for
people for children to help I was still
a child myself my parents did everything
they could to send us to school it took
a lot of effort but we finally bought a
school notebook and a pencil for me I
carried my books or my book in a plastic
bag from the store there was a lot of
poverty in our case it was absolutely
exceptional and a great achievement that
we managed to go to school during
Mexico's presidential campaign in 2012
student protests at Florida's University
kicked off mass demonstrations against
America Pena Nieto
Vilma's Mucha gente society we're now
seeing lots of people going out on the
street to protest young people children
old people because they aren't happy
with a new president deceiving yo soy
una de sus personas guests and I'm one
of those who disapprove of him and I've
also been taking part in the protests
I've been campaigning with groups that
want to express their objections to this
new president that I think what we're
seeing is an attack on Mexican society
on the indigenous peoples and human
rights on the people as a whole I am
well
I have mono contacting me twice I'm
still in touch with people from the
orphanage sometimes they'll send me a
text message or presents on my birthday
it makes me feel mister like a family
Amir is picking up osman a friend from
his time in the orphanage they're going
to visit our birth their former Guardian
at his home in door now goat yeah you
lost some weight
but you're looking good really I just
can't stop eating nice car
we're getting older that's normal
next year I have to get moving on family
life family life I want to start a
family have they found a way for you yet
all I have to do is say yes sure I
really don't want to live alone anymore
yes boring isn't it okay
I'll sit over here can I get you
something to drink we always wanted to
pay Albert a visit we've only been to
your office and now here we are sitting
around my table it's nice we the first
term were the other guys here no you're
the first ones first ones so this is
like a kind of premiere
this is the main shopping street in
don't Albert how much is that jacket it
costs 60 euros but it's a ladies jacket
I'd recommend one for men this coat for
$1.99 for that beautiful scarf the code
is a bit bureaucratic maybe but it's
warm Street over there is a problem more
than Gaza what's it called
Morgan Gaza what's that mean more than
Gaza you don't know what that means more
than boards moon yeah I've heard that
it's an old term for blacks see the
three Moors up there that's so racist
the three black figures they're dancing
right that's right I don't know where
the name comes from I just want them to
change it it's offensive
okay why don't you run for mayor I never
thought about it do you think I could
become there okay then you have to get
citizenship and move here and vote for
me then I'll have a chance don't you
start saying foreigners out no I never
say that
no don't you go hang out with them we
don't want these three wars here Florina
is meeting a friend for dinner they're
sharing an order of slow death a
speciality from Florida's home state of
Oaxaca wait is there another one no
there are seven so three and a half each
right three and a half you get one half
I get the other
are you graduating soon theoretically I
need one more semester here on the home
stretch yes it's very exciting but it's
been very hard I had to work the whole
time I was studying work study I have to
divide myself into three or four people
do you have plans for after you're
finished I'd like to do graduate studies
in human rights maybe and I'd like to go
to Germany to study that sounds good you
were there before and a part of me
stayed there there's some connection but
I identify with Germany the experiences
I had there I felt so free I was
respected I was like another person I
felt different from the way I feel in
Mexico that was six years ago today I
see things differently I don't want to
leave my country for good I see there
are many problems here and they affect
us and we have a responsibility to do
something to do something in this case
especially for the indigenous
communities here for my people my
culture and for the culture of the
others
could I okay oh what a lovely my
thoughts about going to Germany have
changed the idea still appeals to me but
it's no longer about fleeing my country
it's the opposite I can go there and
learn lots of things and then return to
my country and use all that knowledge
here I'm much more aware of just how
many problems we have here in Mexico
my letter machine has found her sister
in Iran to wish her a happy birthday in
Zubov I saw last summer I met someone
and at first I was so delighted and
thought wow I've really hit the bullseye
but after two weeks I realized no this
isn't it well the moment get it for the
time being it's okay I'm just so happy
with my life and my free time and my
work but there's no room for a new
person kind of home it's fine annoy your
pals on Hollande Venice Compton if it
happens it happens
I can't say what plan I have for the
future or what my goal is my goal is to
be happy to find inner peace and just
enjoy life and and to experience
happiness in life good luck in lameness
for Lincoln
- alphabets are very useful for giving
the table 30
somebody decided